So I went through some of the symbolism of the unknown.
I want to go through some of the symbolism that's associated with the known
today.
So give you some sense.
Flags are definitely patriarchal symbols.
There's their cultural symbols,
and here's some.
I'll just lay out every variety of terms.
And so that'll give you some indication of the network of associations that's
associated with the symbol of the dominance hierarchy.
Fundamentally,
culture,
Apple Linnaean control.
That's after Apollo,
the god Super Ego,
the conscious,
the king,
the patriarch,
the plow.
Cause the plow opens up the earth,
the Fallis Order and authority and the crushing weight of tradition,
the wise old man and the tyrant dogma,
the day sky,
the country man,
the island,
the heights,
the ancestral spirits,
and the activity of the dead.
Now these symbolic realms or are kind of there,
there's there
situationally transformable.
So if you look across cultures very frequently in stories,
you see characters that exemplify each of these categories,
but the characters can shift to some degree.
For example,
so often if the story involves the ocean and an island than the ocean will be
feminine in the island.
Will be masculine.
But if the story utilizes an island and the air,
then the island will be feminine in the air,
will be masculine.
So it isn't as if there's a one to one correspondence between the entities in
the story and these architectural categories because their definition depends
on,
they can't be defined in isolation.
So it's,
it's,
it's sort of like does this really stupid example,
but it's the best one I can come up with at the moment.
If you're trying to interpret statistics,
you can't understand what a given statistic means unless you know the number of
people in the experiment,
the effect size and the probability that that effect size is that at emerged at
a better than chance level.
Any of those pieces of information without the other two are actually
meaningless.
And it's the same situation here.
You have to have the representation of culture and you have to have the
representation of nature and you have to have the representation of the
individual and then you can figure out what's,
what entities are being used in those different categories.
Even though there's some similarity across stories,
which is partly why you could actually understand stories,
right?
Because if there was no similarity across them,
then you wouldn't be able to understand them.
So,
um,
there some representations of the great father.